- Transat devra finalement voler
de ses propres ailes.
L'entreprise devait être achetée
par Air Canada. Ottawa avait
déjà donné son accord, ne
manquait plus que l'approbation
de la Commission européenne.
CHRISTOPHE HENNEBELLE, v.-p.,
affaires publiques, Transat A.T
- Nous avons été informés
cette semaine par la Commission
européenne qu'elle prévoyait
de rendre un avis qui serait
négatif.
- Les deux transporteurs
ont préféré abandonner
la transaction, mais il
ne faut pas trop s'en étonner.
Depuis quelques mois,
le mariage semblait
de plus en plus incertain.
MEHRAN EBRAHIMI, directeur, Obs.
aéronautique et aviation civile,
- Cette fusion-là n'avait plus
la force ou l'intérêt que ça
représentait avant la pandémie.
- La COVID-19 a décimé
l'industrie aérienne.
En un peu plus d'un an,
l'offre d'Air Canada pour
acheter Transat est passée de
720 à 190 millions de dollars.
L'homme d'affaires Pierre Karl
Péladeau avait soumis une offre
similaire. Il est désormais
un nouvel acheteur potentiel.
- L'offre est toujours valide,
absolument. L'accord
d'arrangement nous a empêché
d'avoir quelque conversation que
ce soit avec monsieur Péladeau
ou avec quelque autre acheteur
que ce soit. À présent, nous
sommes libres, donc nous allons
pouvoir considérer cette offre.
- Les avions de l'entreprise
québécoise sont cloués
au sol jusqu'à la mi-juin.
Pour poursuivre ses activités
toute seule, elle aura besoin
d'un demi-milliard de dollars et
elle compte sur l'aide d'Ottawa.
- La parole du gouvernement
fédéral dans le transport
aérien, pour moi, aujourd'hui,
ça n'a aucune valeur.
- Cet expert est sceptique.
Il compte davantage sur
l'aide de Québec. En février,
le premier ministre Legault,
cofondateur de Transat,
s'était dit préoccupé.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Mais Air Transat, c'est
une entreprise très importante
au Québec. Et que ce soit
Pierre Karl Péladeau ou
d'autres personnes qui sont
intéressés par le dossier,
on suit ça de très près.
- Air Transat, sans intervention
aujourd'hui, son avenir est
en danger.
- Mais elle pourrait aussi
être un joueur majeur
quand les voyages reprendront,
dans l'après-pandémie.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, M